how's it going bro my name welcome to
Gary Dark Secrets d m it's a full
conversion mod mod requires 1 point I
think I have it yeah I will ruin it if I
don't have patch focus on the story and
atmosphere and don't play to win I'm
pretty good with this thank you very
much also if you want to survive all
right and that's it now have fun and
scream a lot
ah ah my mic I need a new mic they don't
sell stuff in
Italy not stuff that you want at least
you can't get a mic like this and
it I dropped it on this whoa creepy uh
soundtrack did I spell my own name wrong
ah [__] whatever Gary dark secret this
looks pretty interesting let's let's
give it a go everyone just makes full
convention mods these days it's like a
new trender [__] I grabed my micophone
pH on the wooden Stone floor and it said
bye-bye don't record in Stereo anymore
I'm sorry Mikey you were expensive if
anyone is sorry than I am well I guess
that's what I
said seriously this mic is probably
better than you I never gave you a name
maybe that's why I think it's probably
he's probably
pissed anyway it's a big file it's
taking
a while to load so let me just adjust a
couple things in
meanwhile is it better or
worse oh look at that look at that let's
try that ah team Zena
presents Gary Dark
Secrets
oh that's enough TV for me all right I
should go and meet up with Nick so we
don't miss this party's been talking so
much about he's Swedish I can tell by
the accent although I have my suspicions
that this this part is going to blow
we're going to party at an old mansion
sounds more creepy than fun it's
probably going to be dark too and Nick
knows I hate that I better bring my
flashlight some batteries just in case
all right they should be in my desk cool
this is pretty a what but what was I
watching I'm kind of curious probably
Jersey short [__] love now I don't
it's a computer it's the Poma computer
all right it's by my desk there you are
cool and batteries too all right I
should get going now why not let's
go ooh look at that crany stuff dude you
know I hate it when it's dark stop being
such a [__] I'm not a [__] Brier
inside oh you better be right about that
don't worry I will protect you from all
the evil
ghost [__] you man very unique I like
[Music]
it see this isn't so bad this is pretty
[__] bad they have Lions it's
actually kind of cozy no it's not cozy I
don't trust
those I think the living room is this
way that way that way this way okay 4
hours what the [__] all
right hey hey finally stand straight
it's party hey h come over here I want
you to try something this is me at a
party it's my own recipe bro I don't do
drugs bro W it's F I think you've had
enough dude shut up I know what I'm know
[__] weird custom
story oh what the oh you do
huh come on let's put him on the bed so
people don't start dancing on him why
would people dance on me I'm dancing by
Myself dancing by Myself sweet dreams
you little
drunk what the
hell the hell is going
on Gary what the [__] man what did he
that
[__] awesome uh intro so far I love
it it I hope the hopeing the quality
continues I remember I play this a long
time ago I was kind of I was kind of
rough on
him anyway it looks really good so far
enjoying it all
right
whoa oh [__]
me oh the oh oh
[__] oh God what a nightmare ah oh I
really must have drank a lot last
night but at rumbling I just heard it
sounded too real for a dream I better
check what's going on this is my bedroom
now why is my I my my
flashlight all right fine I'm not going
without my flashlight well if I could
[__] see where it
is come on got a Tinder bar it's so
dark maybe in the closet I got my
sexy all right maybe here a there it is
thank
you ah thank God ah thank God all right
let's
go blood why is there blood everywhere
someone need oh my God what the hell
happened here why aren't they naked
whoa this is actually really cool I mean
creepy
also wow look at that what the hell whoa
they party hard at this party holy [__]
they must have taken some weird drug hey
P whoa I must be still on drugs too this
H is talking to me hey P what's going on
p i oh [__] my life I'm out
here ah what the hell was
that hand what did he go Andy
Andy where did he
go [__] all right let's grab that [__]
sedet tabs the [__] is that
nope nope nope nope nope
nope let's keep
investigating
all so [__]
all right let's go I guess just taking
slow what are you doing
bro waa they got is this a puma models I
think so it's pretty cool they're lot
scientists and [__] what was
that ah [__] me we got to go there all
right
[__] hello
what what is he doing under the bed hey
bro you party too hard like God damn it
I get the feeling I need to look for
something all right found it wasn't that
difficult oh come
on H where the [__] am I doing in here
all right let's use this
key uh well I don't know then what
where's the
archiv maybe it's the door that was over
here I sure hope
so I don't know it's like stuff
everywhere to look
for please don't do anything okay ah
okay I lost f
did you drink too much again Jesus
Christ you're not a real Viking but I am
from
Sweden come on span don't
drop hi py calm down I'm with you
there's a secret route that leads out of
here you can find the levers down in the
study go the rest is unreadable because
it's all a
period what the [__] man go the in the
study I'll find the lever in the study
is there any treats for me here oh thank
God morphine even better thank God no
just kidding there's nothing better than
morphine
really all
right ah barely [__] Focus man is
this
your really what you do don't make a
noise bar what did I did I just say
Jesus Christ all
right grab
that all right we need to find a lever
is this the
archives he said down in the
archives all right it's got to be down
here I pay it this way I guide you no
worries I am in I'm French I know this
sh oh
[__] all right I'll let you go for the
funer hello
this is it py be careful up Jesus how
you doing hey py love your nipples all
right a lever in the
archives where is
it can we go
here
oh nailed it damn this is some creepy
[__] creepy
[__] all right let's keep going I want
to see what
happens sorry we have to lose theana
though but I'm sure we'll find him Love
Will Find
way so the lever for that secret ride is
supposed to be here somewhere I have to
look
carefully all
right it's nice with instructions I
always feel so lost when I play Hey
piano let it
be let it be be Let It
Be what's that [__]
noises Let It Be whisper words of wisdom
let it be it's not here let's keep
looking I
guess Su damn someone made a mess a big
mess I don't like
m is that behind
me
it's so [__]
dark this flashlight isn't doing [__]
it's not doing
[Music]
[__] all right let's keep going
inside who that's a big ass clock I
really like the level of this sign it's
pretty cool damn some a lot of door whoa
what the [__] is
this I'm I'm
what are you doing
there don't think I don't trust you even
though you're a
Jennifer oh [__]
oh okay it just fell down the floor it's
not what are you doing did you afford
did you set that trap for me I didn't
py [__] just [__] all right God damn
it how are we supposed to go up
again we're good
I'm looking at you [__] hate you
piece of come back
here all
right here we
go nothing wrong with being up look
we're going up it's not a
problem I actually like going
up I don't know about you bre what is
this am I supposed to use
this
probably yeah like something out you
I'll keep it there for
now oh okay cool that wasn't so
bad let's use the
BRD don't [__]
up I'm actually out of time here but
really cool cousin story I think it will
get even more scarier once we get into
it but uh yeah like if you enjoyed
subsscribe to come BR today and I'll see
you next episode of whever I make stay
awesome
bro don't tell you can watch your door
oh thank God that was close I actually
want to see
him
hello wa you're so
sexy what the a